love yous
you're a brave girl so what's the story
young lady we're on our way to
Minneapolis it wasn't an accident
nice out well sooner or later everybody
does right dad I nearly had you tonight
since you're traveling I'd like to do a
cat scan daddy's gonna take care of I'm
gonna wait right here for you when you
get out 15 hours you know how much
longer it's gonna be what was her name
again Harry Monroe
I'm not seeing a Perry Monroe there
hasn't been a scan since 9 o'clock this
morning
what are you telling me they're not here
at the whole day in front of you not
finding any Monroe I just want to see my
wife and daughter don't record in the
treatment areas all right that the
camera can't see them because of the
chairs you get a better angle
you saw my little girl you treated her
own well I've got to go on is your word
that they were here at all thinks I'm
making come on
why would I have my daughter scarf but
not her there's something wrong with
this place should you the picture that
could be anybody
where's concerned about them as you are
nobody needs to get hurt I mean he's a
head case
[Music]
you